hallo leute ich es wieder einmal wann
und willkommen zu einem neuen bett
kalender unboxing das letzte jahr wieder
so reingehauen hat heinz mittelmeer ich
+ ich muss ehrlich gestehen ich kenne
mich mit dem ehrlich brothers nicht so
aus ich weiß dass sie ziemlich speziell
aussehen und dass sie zaubern können und
diese ganzen zaubertricks haben sie mit
uns in diesem teil adventskalender
geteilt meine ganzen juli mails können
hier die beauty adventskalender
auspacken davon gibt es ja schon wieder
hunderte videos auf youtube
aber wer würde sich an einen zauber
adventskalender trauen natürlich nur ich
wie bewerten sie diesen adventskalender
waren gar nicht so schlecht messung habe
ich hoffnung dass der spaß machen wird
natürlich sein dass nur die hardcore
ehrlich bürgers fans kalender gespielt
haben
da wirst du schon richtig ehrlich
browsers fällen wenn du dass dir so auf
links und jetzt fangen wir an mit dem
türchen nummer eins im magic vier
spielkarten ok tag 1 10 prozent
preisvorteil zum nächsten show die vier
zauberhaften damen a ha du findest ohne
zu zögern heraus welche der vier damen
ein zuschauer gewählt hat ein auge jeder
dame ist rot bemalt hat also ich habe
das gefühl dass der erste trägt so eine
ziemliche verarsche ist weil die damen
sind haid markiert somit den augen und
ja ich lege die karten jetzt so hin und
der andere soll die karte umdrehen sich
anschauen und wieder hinlegen wenn
verschicken den sprit brauchen deine
assistenz such dir eine dame aus und
zeigt sie dem publikum und legt sie
danach wieder hin will denkt an diese
karte heißt die hier ja okay so trick
ist kann ich verstehen war richtig die
haben ein rot angemalten auge und die
sollte so irgendwie zu dir drehen und
dann soll der zuschauer ja mal der
zuschauer soll dann die karte nimmt die
leuten zeigen und er wird sie dann
falsch rum wieder hinlegen weil die
roten augen zu mir gerichtet sind aber
du hast sie halt genauso wieder hin
links was macht man denn dann aber
zurzeit trägt nummer zwei wir lassen uns
davon nicht unterkriegen vielleicht
klappt es mit dem zweiten satz besser
ihr abonniert jetzt alle diesen kanal
wird auf meine videos zu schauen ohne
ein abo aktiviert die glocke ist dass
hypnose nach einer kurzen hypnose hat
ein zuschauer den eindruck dass sich
dein gesicht verformt ihr meint optische
täuschung wird ist einfach noch optische
täuschung und keine magic ich hasse es
ich hoffe mein gott sie muss und sie im
lsd fühlen jetzt ist es wieder weg
ok ich meine es ist beeindruckend kinder
denke ich würde jetzt nicht fertig
nennen sie ein rotes tuch jetzt brauchst
du noch einen stil blitzschnelle tuch
erscheinung beginne damit das tuch wie
in foto 1 auf seinem kriegen zusammen zu
drücken
die durch das tuch kügelchen versteckst
du in der armbeuge des rechten arms
zeige nur den zuschauer deine hände von
beiden seiten oder fragt
seid ihr bereit hier meine hände sind
komplett frei und jetzt mit seht ihr
meine hände sind komplett frei oh mein
gott und jetzt lasst ihr ein tuch
erscheinen
okay es ist schon sehr magic number wir
glauben das herz der karten es ist halt
ein duell der könig der täuschung eine
von vier königs daten mit den zuschauern
gewählt du hast die wahl vorausgesehen
für dieses unvergesslichen trick ist
eine gründliche vorbereitung notwendig
wichtig kreuz und paten werden auch als
schwarze karten herz und karo partner zu
rote karten bezeichnet
sekunden später den soll mein assistent
die karte ziehen und ich habe die wahl
vorausgesehen bereiten
ok in diesem stapel befinden sich vier
königs kartensuche eine aus links
meister ok glaube an das herz der karten
war es gut
[Musik]
okay das hat jetzt einfach mal
funktioniert es gibt fünf sterne auf
amazon türchen nummer fünf eine münze
mit dem ehrlich basis drauf eine münze
verschwindet und unverschämt trägt ja
eine mütze verschwindet in dem du darauf
tust es klappt noch nicht
dieses grundstück machst du mit einer
schein übergabe ich lasse jetzt eine
müll verschwinden also schaut auf die
münze
[Musik]
wir müssen hier steht aber auch dass es
zu den grundbegriffen der
fortgeschrittenen zauberkunst ist also
ist das was schon üben muss
das sind aber so zaubertricks die würde
ich gerne zum alter können einfach nur
um leute so ein bisschen zu beeindrucken
ich meine machst du so co2 einem
interview
sechs mal geschah plastikteller das
wunder der zwei münzen eine münze
wandert aus einer tasche in deiner
handelsriesen zauber assistent werde
diese münzen jetzt vermehrt machen
nehmen sie mal in die hand und guck mal
sind es ganz normale münzen
[Musik]
sind es ganz normale mensch eigentümer
zu ersten blick hier stabil
okay das ist nur zum extra immer noch
normale menschen wie schalen nichts
unter den fingern alles super und
[Musik]
schieben was hast du ein schnürsenkel
die blitz entlasten wenn die erklärung
denn jetzt noch so lagen obwohl deine
handgelenke gut gefesselt sind beweist
du dich im bruchteil einer sekunde und
für auch kurz gut und spiele ich bin so
haben
der kraftmeier geladen diese kann ich
mich festlegen vielleicht war das auch
so cool aus müsste jetzt mal ganz cool
aussieht und nein ich bin gefesselt oder
doch nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die salz wanderung mein gott der tricks
sind so kompliziert aus zwei stunden
später
ok also du versteckst da salz drin dann
machst du deinen daumen rein dann machst
du wieso und dann machst du seit sie den
salzstreuer so habe das getränk okay
[Musik]
für ihn normal wie spielkarten minikarte
nein zuschauer ist nicht in der lage die
position der einzigen roten karte zu
markieren doch habe ich gerade geschafft
das ist kein zaubertrick das ist wieder
mal einfach nur eine optische illusion
oben ist es anders gedruckt als unten
das heißt du sagst halt markiere mit der
büroklammer die rote karte dann macht
jemand da die klammer drauf weil es ja
die mitte ist dann drehte es um oder sie
schwarze karte markiert ja nummer 10
das bedeutet auch immer mobil dann der
verhexte bleistift ein auf dem tisch
liegende bleistift bewegt sich auf
mysteriöse weise leute das ist eine
schnur und eine karte mit mache ich
nicht nur die ehrlich brothers die
befreiung der ehrlich brothers die
ehrlich brothers werden im gefängnis
fast verschlossen einmal magisch pusten
und sie sind wieder frei das ganze
findest du diesmal nicht wirklich statt
sondern nur mit den bildern der ehrlich
brandes anfängen ist ich weiß ich habe
kein cooler trick nummer 12 da klebt ein
stück tiefer die zauber keine eine
zauberhafte bierwirth aus deiner hand
wachsen du bist selbst von dem ergebnis
überrascht sein dass du mit einigen
einfachen papierstreifen erzielen kann
storyboards das gummiband ist weg ein
etwa schlechte verpackung nummer am 13
ich warte jetzt einfach nur noch mal auf
den guten zauberer trägt ansonsten bin
ich hier auch durch mit der geschichte
ich glaub ich hab es kaputt gemacht im
herbst kaputtgemacht gut und das war
trick nummer 13
das muss es doch aushalten oder 14
ehrlich brenner
wenn wir schon so ein garten schlage
gekommen wo dann auch eine ein großes
schwarzes access kann sich schon
vorstellen dass dieser zaubertrick nicht
so toll sein wird drei karten werden von
deinen zuschauer gelegt die karte mit
den ehrlich börse wandert an den drei
karten soweit der zuschauer sagt an
einer beliebigen stelle statt die gebete
karte ist von mir vorher gesagt zwei
stunden später
man lachte man lernt diese coole basic
zaubersprüche zaubersprüche vor allem in
gali um liu sa 15 groß oder klein 2
geborene papst reifen scheinen ihre
länge zu ändern ist eine optische
täuschungen mal wieder also wir haben
wir zwei identisch große karten und er
zieht mal die gelbe ziehen länger euro
sind sie doch nicht so gleich groß match
okay kriegt die gelbe mal wieder besitz
und gerne mit ihm zusammen passen
jetzt sind sie wieder gleich groß ein
toller trick den free kann ich als kind
wirklich gefeiert nummer 16 1 1
doch halt stopp da ist ein loch in ein
tuch wird zum 1
okay erinnert ihr euch noch an das tuch
so ich stopp bis jetzt in meiner hand
richtig gut in meiner hand versteckt
[Musik]
und jetzt ist es 1 1
wo ist das touren verschwunden keine
ahnung wollen wir das tuch zurückholen
okay und jetzt haben wir nur noch das
tuch nummer 15 uhr ein staat mit
glitzersteinen der diamanten starb wenn
die beschreibung wieder so lange
diamanten erscheinen und verschwinden
auf einem stab und wechsel lief war ich
kann dir man nur hin und her zaubern
stellt die farbe gewechselt das gesehen
zauberei nummer 18 aus marl will doch
ein es verbirgt sich auch hier ein
zaubertrick dahinter hoffe ich hexe oder
jungen frau auf einem bild sind zwei
unterschiedliche personen zu erkennen um
ein gott endlich die hexe vor habe ich
nur die jungfrau gesehen ich hoffe ihr
könnt auch die könnte an dieser stelle
pausieren falls ihr euch das anschauen
wollt also ich werde die hexe und die
jungs ein bisschen wie laurel und janin
jährige mal wieder optische täuschung 19
nay noch eine klammer und ein gutes
gummiband und ein schnürsenkel nachdem
du die zuschauer darauf
[Gelächter]
dazu braucht man natürlich wieder hier
unser cooles crazy ding etwas
kaputtgegangen zahlen danke
20 nersingen
also jetzt ist aber teuer sie die drei
seile ein langes und ein mittler
mittellanges und ein kurzes teil
verwandeln sich in drei gleich lange
seile später ja gut dieser trick ist
halt so dass man
wird so alles so rum knotet und so rum
wurden so umgestellt dass es dann am
ende halt alles aussieht und drei gleich
lange seile da
21.18 uhr durch post mit einem bleistift
eine spielkarte doch wenn du den
bleistift herausschießt karte plötzlich
wieder ganz okay leute ein ganz normaler
bleiben schätzt und eine ganz normale
karte jetzt durch bericht diese karte
mit meinem bleistift ist durchbohrt und
wenn ich sie jetzt raus ist die karte
wieder ganz frage mich wie die zauberer
einfach so präparierte sachen haben wir
mich so tricks einfach machen nummer 22
money money money sauber geld leihen
gates schwebt über deine handfläche
das ist so bescheuert das ist schon
wieder geil finde den guardian lewis
sieht die wieder geld schon über meine
handfläche 23 die sächsischen karten
oder einfach nur die sechs präparierten
karten dass man andere leute verarschen
kann und schon wieder rennen von
karl-heinz dort nein das sind ganz
normale karten ganz normal ja das ist
halt einfach wieder so ein trick so
verarscht
wir sind angekommen beim letzten türchen
eine menge mai ich wünsche mir einen
kleinen trick dabei ein kleine crazy
school die welt ohne routine dieser lern
erst mal zu sprechen bevor du zaubern
willst also leute ich habe hier eine
stinknormale schach dort packe ich nun
eine schiene
so und jetzt kenne ich die schnur magic
und wieder zusammen
das ist saubere ehrlich brothers mein
fazit zu diesem adventskalender was sich
positiv finde ist dass ich glaube dass
die sich wirklich gedanken gemacht haben
was für zaubertricks wieder einpacken
wollen wie sie so kleine überraschungen
für jeden tag machen ist es auch gemeint
ich bin ja nicht so liegt größte zauber
tante die sich die zaubertricks
interessiert und ich habe mich auch ganz
oft entertain gefühlt also besonders
diese kleine schachtel hier am ende
kannst mal im geschmack wieder die
schale lieber auf gut andere
zaubertricks wiederum fand ich jetzt
nicht so bombe und besonders wenn man
alle zaubertricks hintereinander
versucht einem der kopf ganz schön
deswegen glaube ich so wenn man jeden
tag ein türchen ausmaß und sich dann mit
dem zaubertrick beschäftigt besonders
wenn man ein zaubertricks richtig
interessiert ist dann ist es schon
cooler kalender also falls ihr
geschwister oder so habe die ehrlich
browsers fans sind und kleine zauberer
sind dann überlegt euch doch mal statt
schokolade oder so dass auch cool berlin
nicht gedacht ist es am ende sagen und
ich habe schon einen wenigsten
adventskalender das kann
boylan der wird sehr cool ich freue mich
darauf und ich hoffe ihr auch wenn euch
das video gefallen hat gerne mit dem
daumen nach oben zeigen und abonniert
den kanal wenn ihr es noch nicht getan
habt aktiviert die glocke wenn ihr es
noch nicht getan haben wir auf instagram
wenn ihr das nicht getan habt ich habe
echt vergleichsweise wenig vorlauf
instagram und ich verstehe dich ganz
genau woran es liegt wahrscheinlich weil
ich da nicht so aktiven also bin ich
schon aber immer mal wieder nicht so und
dann doch aber alle anderen haben mehr
hannover anliegen na gut leute dann eure
[Musik]